[Música]
el gobierno del presidente de
estadounidense joe by del compartirá con
distintos países 60 millones de vacunas
de astrazéneca cuando la administración
de drogas y alimentos del país se
entregue el aval de su uso aunque no se
ha especificado se espera que parte de
estas vacunas sean destinadas a india
país colapsado por el virus la oms se
advierte que debido a los esfuerzos
mundiales por vacunar masivamente a la
población contra el coronavirus se ha
pausado 60 campañas de vacunación y casi
la mitad son contra el sarampión una de
las patologías más contagiosas que causa
una mayor mortalidad infantil
la guerrilla del care n una de las
facciones rebeldes más grandes de
mianmar anunció que atacó y tomó una
base del ejército cerca de la frontera
tailandesa las tensiones entre los
militares y los grupos armados en el
país se han intensificado desde el golpe
de estado del primero de febrero debido
a la violencia y la represión contra los
civiles
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 si raúl blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos en eeuu el gobierno de ese
país anunció que exportará hasta 60
millones de dosis de la vacuna de
astrazéneca aunque la casa blanca no ha
dicho que países recibirán las dosis ni
cuando se enviarán exactamente la medida
supone un cambio de rumbo para eeuu la
administración en bailén ha sido acusada
de acumular vacunas cuando se necesitan
desesperadamente en el extranjero
dispuestos a compartir las preciadas
vacunas pero la promesa de la casa
blanca de exportar 60 millones de dosis
de astrazéneca viene con un
inconveniente las inyecciones no pueden
ser enviadas al extranjero hasta que
sean autorizadas por los reguladores
estadounidenses
sólo para ser claros en este momento
tenemos cero dosis disponibles de 'las
transgénica la administración de
alimentos medicamentos tiene que pasar
por una revisión para garantizar la
seguridad
esperamos que hay aproximadamente 10
millones de dosis que podrían ser
distribuidas sólo cuando la idea de su
consentimiento lo que podría ocurrir en
las próximas semanas más de la mitad de
la población adulta de eeuu ya ha
recibido una primera inoculación
mientras que otros países como india
necesitan desesperadamente vacunas yobái
de nabucco narendra modi el lunes
prometiendo insumos médicos pero la casa
blanca no especificó si las vacunas
serían parte de esa ayuda una ayuda que
no es sólo altruista
cada variante que hemos visto surgir en
esta pandemia ha acabado en eeuu no hay
forma de aislarse así que aunque lo
hagamos por razones egoístas todos
deberíamos comprometernos a ayudar a los
países a mantener sus brotes bajo
control y prestar especial atención a
países como india que tienen una
población tan grande y tantas
infecciones que se están registrando en
este momento a diferencia de china a
rusia y la unión europea que han estado
exportando mientras inoculaban eeuu ha
sido criticado por acumular vacunas el
mes pasado prestaron dosis a méxico y
canadá y ahora esta nueva promesa
constituye un cambio significativo en
las primeras incursiones de washington
en la diplomacia de las vacunas
es que efectivamente uno de los países
que más necesita ayuda en este momento
es india aunque este martes tuvo un
respiro con el primer descenso de
contagios y muertes la grave crisis
sanitaria por la pandemia está haciendo
que la comunidad internacional se
solidarice los primeros en socorrer a
nueva delhi la capital son los
británicos que enviaron 100 ventiladores
y 95 contenedores de oxígeno y ahora
anuncian que desplegarán más de 600
unidades de equipo médico vital sin
embargo sus habitantes están abrumados
por la explosión de casos de kobe 19 y
por la falta de respuesta de las
autoridades sanitarias
mi padre se encuentra en una condición
muy crítica no recibimos ayuda nos dan
números telefónicos de líneas de ayuda
pero nadie responde los números no están
disponibles por favor ayúdenme por favor
mi padre se está muriendo no puedo
afrontar otra perdida ayer perdí a mi
hermano menor
mientras tanto la organización mundial
de la salud advirtió que la lucha para
frenar la pandemia de 19-9 de librarse
en detrimento de los esfuerzos para
combatir otras enfermedades como la
polio o el sarampión patologías mortales
que afectan sobre todo a la población
infantil y que se pueden prevenir la
brecha generada a raíz de la pandemia
pone en potencial riesgo la salud de más
de 220 millones de personas en todo el
mundo principalmente en los países menos
favorecidos son naciones unidas quiere
tratar esta problemática con una campaña
de inmunización masiva de cara al año
2030 informe de rosa pérez más de eeuu
mientras el mundo concentra sus
esfuerzos en la vacunación para frenar
la expansión del nuevo corona virus la
oms advierte que millones de niños están
expuestos a la contracción de otras
enfermedades tan mortales como evitables
sobre todo en áfrica de base si existe
que a pesar que las vacunas contra el
coi 19 nos dan esperanza al final del
túnel la pandemia ha provocado múltiples
perturbaciones en los servicios de
inmunización alrededor del mundo round
the world
y nuevos datos de la ong se muestran que
como resultado del 1960 campañas de
inmunización están actualmente
suspendidas en 50 países fifty countries
esto significa que cerca de 228 millones
de niños son vulnerables actualmente a
enfermedades prevenibles tales como el
sarampión la fiebre amarilla o la polio
isla meals yellow fever
segúnla o ms de las 60 campañas pausadas
casi la mitad son contra el sarampión
una de las patologías más contagiosas y
que causa una mayor mortalidad infantil
desde hace 50 años se dispone de fármaco
para prevenirla
en 2016 el 85% de los niños y niñas del
mundo recibieron la vacuna antes de
cumplir un año
naciones unidas- indica que esta
inmunización generalizada salvó más de
20 millones de vidas entre 2000 y 2016
pero desde entonces los casos han vuelto
a aumentar
incluso antes de la pandemia ya estamos
perdiendo terreno en la lucha contra las
enfermedades infantiles evitables
20 millones de niños se estaban quedando
fuera de una vacunación necesaria y
situaría al sarampión y la polio en la
cabeza de mi lista
y ahora un año después del inicio de la
pandemia de kobe 19 seguimos perdiendo
terreno para revertir la tendencia la
oms anunció una nueva estrategia de
vacunación mundial con la que pretende
reducir a la mitad de 20 a 10 millones
la población infantil que no reciben
ninguna vacuna y salvar así 50 millones
de vidas para 2030
y la crisis sanitaria por cuenta de la
pandemia se agrava en américa latina' a
poco más de un año desde que aparecieran
los primeros casos positivos se están
registrando unas cifras récords que
preocupan a las autoridades y a pesar de
que el proceso de vacunación ya comenzó
en varios países latinoamericanos no
avanza tan rápido como algunos esperan a
diferencia de las ciudades es difícil la
distribución de las vacunas en zonas
remotas donde viven las comunidades
indígenas para hablar sobre el proceso
de vacunación de estas comunidades
quiero saludar en este momento a darío
mejía montalvo indígena del pueblo sen
gracias por estar con nosotros señor
mejía montalvo le preguntó qué tan
complejo han resultado los procesos de
vacunación en las comunidades indígenas
buenos días muchas gracias por su
invitación
los pueblos indígenas de toda la región
antes de esta pandemia ya padecían los
problemas propios del desamparo estatal
las vías de acceso principalmente son
una de las dificultades más grandes
además de la falta de comprensión y de
traducción a sus idiomas maternos lo
cual dificulta en sí mismo la
posibilidad de que accedan a las vacunas
además de todas las dificultades de
exclusión
y racismo que todavía vivimos
lamentablemente en nuestra región por
esa razón en este momento además de los
otros problemas que se están enfrentando
como la falta de tierras la presión
sobre sus territorios y sobre sus
recursos de además de todo deben
enfrentarse a estar en la última parte
de la cola frente al proceso de
vacunación en la región ahora debería
además de esto le quiero preguntar si
hay resistencia en muchas personas a lo
mejor de la tercera edad que desconfían
de la vacuna debido a su creencia en las
medicinas tradicionales a base de
plantas y otras y también las
recomendaciones de los líderes
religiosos
bueno sobre esto puede haber mucho que
discutir seguramente habrán pueblos que
confían mucho en su medicina tradicional
sin embargo lo importante es que estén
disponibles las vacunas que las personas
tengan la capacidad de decidir si la
colocan o no la colocan creo que en este
momento para las comunidades indígenas
y decidir sobre algo que no está
presente también se convierte en una
discusión etérea pienso que lo
importante en este momento es que
podamos generar campañas a nivel
continental para que exista un mecanismo
de acceso a los pueblos indígenas para
las vacunas sin que se convierta en un
mecanismo de presión frente a sus
demandas actuales que también siguen
siendo muy importantes en temas como las
otras enfermedades que también padecen
las comunidades indígenas y que están
siendo muy fuertes en este momento y de
eso les quería preguntar y ahí va
orientaba mi tercera pregunta cómo es la
situación sanitaria actual de las
comunidades indígenas en nuestras
regiones y cuáles son las más afectadas
era una de las principales afectaciones
que es el hambre muchas de nuestras
comunidades como en el norte de colombia
en la guajira en el chop o en la
amazonía misma están padeciendo de
muchas enfermedades asociadas a la
malnutrición y a la escasez de agua
potable
enfermedades que son ya superadas en el
resto de la humanidad todavía siguen
estando presente en las comunidades
indígenas principalmente en la niñez y
en la tercera edad asociadas a
enfermedades pulmonares a enfermedades
de la piel principalmente darío gracias
por su tiempo y por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 que tenga usted un
feliz resto día nosotros continuamos con
más informaciones cni en mar
la guerrilla étnica unión nacional karen
atacó ya ocupó este martes un puesto
fronterizo del ejército birmano en el
este del país en medio del aumento de
las hostilidades tras el golpe de estado
del pasado primero de febrero que deja
más de 750 fallecidos por la brutal
represión de las protestas antigolpistas
que se viven replicando en todo el país
desde entonces marina sardinia nos
amplía
se intensifican las utilidades en
mianmar este martes estallaron los
enfrentamientos en el estado de karen en
el sureste del país luego de que la
guerrilla étnica unión nacional karen
tomara un puesto del ejército birmano
cerca de la frontera tailandesa en
respuesta a la junta militar golpista
está lanzando ataques aéreos sobre
posiciones de los insurgentes provocando
el desplazamiento de cientos de locales
la junta militar lanzó ataques aéreos en
el área de la brigada 5 del kn el martes
por la tarde según los medios locales el
ataque se produce después de que el kn
capturar a una base de la junta militar
en la frontera entre tailandia y mianmar
hoy por la mañana la unión nacional
karen ha aumentado sus operaciones en
las últimas semanas como respuesta a la
violenta represión de las
manifestaciones prodemocracia por parte
del tal modo que dejan más de 750
fallecidos desde el golpe de estado
militar del 1 de febrero que ha desatado
una crisis social y humanitaria en
mianmar cantando en birmano su
disposición de luchar por el pueblo unos
120 jóvenes se estarían entrenando con
las guerrillas étnicas para hacer frente
a la violencia de los militares
se autodenominan como fuerza de defensa
unida formada por ex manifestantes
antigolpistas que cansados de las
masacres del ejército se habrían
levantado en armas ex manifestantes en
mianmar se están entrenando con grupos
étnicos armados para enfrentarse a la
junta militar después de huir de las
sangrientas represiones este grupo se
llama a sí mismo la fuerza de defensa
unida las últimas hostilidades se
producen días después de que el jefe de
la junta militar asistiera a una cumbre
regional de la asean donde acordó poner
fin a la violencia y entablar el diálogo
las manifestaciones continúan
replicándose en otras regiones del país
pidiendo la liberación de los presos
políticos el fin de la represión y la
restauración de la democracia la
vicepresidenta de eeuu que ama el javis
se prometió más ayuda a centroamérica
para frenar la migración hacia su país
durante una reunión virtual con el
presidente de guatemala alejandro
giammattei harris quien encabeza los
esfuerzos del gobierno de joe biden para
atender la afluencia de migrantes de
guatemala honduras y el salvador aseguró
que habrá una oportunidad para las
personas que se pueden quedar que se
queden en el país señaló
es crear una estrategia integral de
manera bilateral y multilateral con
organizaciones internacionales queremos
trabajar con ustedes para abordar las
causas agudas así como las causas
profundas de una manera que brinde
esperanza al pueblo de guatemala de que
habrá una oportunidad para ellos si se
quedan en casa para tener éxito el
trabajo requerirá la participación de
todos también voluntad política y
trabajo duro para lograr nuestros
objetivos pero estoy segura de que
podemos avanzar y de que podemos crear
un sentido de esperanza para el futuro y
de esta manera llegamos al final de este
informativo de france 24 continue con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias muy buen día y hasta pronto
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo
desde julio de 2020 un millón